[Music]
good morning
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
i'm gonna get you out
are you hurt
are you hurt
[Music]
people need to know that the shaking
is not over
we'll get hit again
and it's going to be a bigger monster
oh my god
the earth
will literally
crack open
and you will feel it
on the east coast
i love you dad
i cannot emphasize this enough
you need to get out and i mean now
if you can't
god be with you
all right hold on we gotta get over it
before i crash
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this mass suicide adhered to the mayan
calendar which predicts the end of time
to occur on the 21st of december of this
year
this year
this year
what are the odds
i thought we'd have more time
[Music]
[Music]
i said that the government is building
these ships
so when do we let the people know
our mission is to assure the continuity
of our species
wasn't it also decided that people have
the right to fight for their lives
so
no matter what happens
we'll all stay together
find out the truth search 2012.
if you're watching this thing you know
by now a huge problem is heading our way
an emergency meeting is being called our
usual place immediately three bagels
i've made a shocking discovery
i need you to get me in touch with nasa
immediately well nasa and i aren't
really on speaking terms these days oh
that'll change
when you tell them that the moon is out
of orbit
there's no need to panic not spacey
why are they lying about all this
it's too late to stop
you knew all this was happening before
nasa
you're the unidentified source oh yes
we're dealing with an intelligent entity
we're planning a mission to attack this
thing
i'm asking you for your help
say yes brian
i need you to be brave
if the moon really is what you think it
is
suit up
horizon you have got a big gravity
weight coming your way you have to
launch now did he say gravity wave
we're underwater guys
that's crazy
itself
wait for it
let's go you son
[Music]
[Music]
it's on airplane mode
[Music]
[Music]
meteorologists
we prepare to go live to los angeles
this is just massive
[Music]
a wall of water coming towards new york
city everybody
save as many as you can
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
seek shelter immediately
what do you think it is no idea
oh my god
the only thing people want to talk about
today is this interstellar comet called
clark nasa's saying it appeared out of
nowhere from like a different solar
system
this is the fragment entering the lower
atmosphere three
two
one an impact where's the explosion it's
a chunk of rock rocks don't explode yeah
tell that to the dinosaurs
[Music]
the sky's on fire
come on let's go
with the largest fragment expected to
hit in less than 24 hours space agencies
are expecting an extinction-level event
the greatest chance of survival near the
bunkers in greenland
we're gonna go
gotta go now okay
[Music]
you're such a brave guy you
know where i will get us under those
bunkers
because we're always going to be
together
pg-13 on demand everywhere december 18th
it was a groundbreaking ceremony for a
new factory
did she mention seeing anyone who was
sick anyone on a plane at the airport
no she said she was jet lagged
[Music]
the average person touches their face
three to five times every waking minute
in between we're touching doorknobs
water fountains and each other
no no go up to your room honey so we
have a virus with no treatment protocol
and no vaccine at this time
as of last night there were 32 cases
unfortunately she did die
right
can i go talk to her mr amos your wife
is dead
what are you talking about what happened
to her
what happened to
is there any way someone could weaponize
the bird flu is that what we're looking
at someone doesn't have to weaponize the
bird flu
the birds are doing that
watch this it's transmission so we just
need to know which direction on day one
there were two people and then four and
then sixteen in three months it's a
billion that's where we're heading
they're calling out the national guard
they're moving the president underground
people will pay
get away it will tip over the truth is
being kept from the world cook your
samples destroy everything
hello
i need you to get me the names of
everyone who serves this room it's an
emergency
i got people too dr cheever
we all do
don't talk to anyone don't touch anyone
stay away from other people
[Applause]
it's figuring us out faster than we're
figuring it out it's mutated
the senate committee will now hear from
jacob lawson climate iss chief
coordinator may the record reflect that
he was nearly one hour late yeah sorry
about that i literally had to fly in
from outer space
thanks to the system of satellites
natural disasters have become a thing of
the past
[Music]
we can control our weather
mr person one of our thermospheric
satellites malfunctioned over
afghanistan
so your proposal is what we shut down
all satellites
i don't need to remind all of you how
many people died from catastrophic
climate conditions make sure there's no
further incidents
are you going back up to space i'm
coming back i promise
have a safe trip sir just don't touch
anything
this is mr jake lawson z jake lawson you
look
much older than i would have thought
i i mean you're good
am i getting fired
my axis has been blocked so satellite
has a bad calm that happens
not a satellite all of it
this wasn't a malfunction it was
intentional
there's potential for catastrophic
weather events on a global scale
a geostorm
we have to shut the system down
the only one who has the killcoats is
the president
and in your health you're soliciting a
secret service agent
seriously we're kidnapping the president
in a self-driving cab
jake if you can't stop it no i can't
three
two come on baby
[Music]
you realize you're committing treatment
oh yeah i kidnapped the president i'm
stolen state secrets yeah anything i'm
forgetting honey
honey
barrier
[Music]
it was the jewel
of our empire
[Music]
what is your name my name is
for survival tomorrow we fight
the slaves that live earned freedom
from all corners of the roman world
can you feel that
we lived in the shadow
of a greater power
[Music]
whatever is happening here
we find freedom my friend
we have to get to the harbour
[Music]
right
now you need to give me a fossil i will
i want to be able to hold it up and say
my daddy tames the dinosaurs
we are big company
millions moving parts
hey how you doing man we all work very
hard to ensure those moving parts are
functioning as a means to very profit
wind for all of us
[Music]
hey come close to the computer move
those eyes
[Music]
no that is a genuine dinosaur tooth
she's gonna flip out
good man mike
[Music]
mike what is that is everything okay
[Music]
[Music]
this is deepwater horizon what's wrong
[Music]
you gotta get to the lifeboats right now
my wife's
and i will see them again do you
understand me
boys come and see this isn't that great
[Music]
oh
the most scary bit for me
and the water hit
when i came up
that was all my own
and then i saw the two of you
i didn't feel so scared anymore
if mommy and lucas are on their own
right now
i'm going to keep looking for them
scared
[Music]
you're good at it
[Music]
i will find them i promise you that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you